[Music]
[Applause]
as Jared mentioned I'll be talking a bit
about go um a little bit um about myself
well actually before we get to that um
told most people in here um obviously
have some familiarity with r how many
people
uh primarily use R for their uh for
their statistical work all right how
many people use something other than R
primarily what would that be python
python anything anything about python
Julia Julia okay interesting um mat lab
anyone okay mat lab
Ruby okay thank God anyway um so okay so
uh I asked that this this uh
presentation is aimed primarily assuming
that you're coming from a background in
either python or R um and uh we'll talk
a little bit first just about what it's
like to migrate to go as a general
purpose programming language if you're
coming from those languages and then
also a little bit about what some of the
um special advantages that go has with
respect to um data science and
statistical programming so um first a
little bit about myself um I studied
computer science and statistics uh at
Columbia um uh I also worked on the
server engineer team at um at forsquare
uh where I worked on the explore
recommendation engine um that was work
done uh mostly in Python and R um before
that I was on the OK Cupid data team
where I did research for um OK Trends
blog posts um and then most recently
I've been the hacker and Residence at um
cottian Ventures there also hack and Y
fellow um in 2011 I think we actually
have some other hack and Y fellows um in
the audience tonight um so uh how many
people here have actually used go before
at all actually a fair number um for
those of you you aren't familiar with it
um let's just get start with a little
bit of go history um go was first
announced in um 2009 that was the first
time that any that the public world had
ever heard about go though actually it
traces its roots back much further than
that the um the creators of go um Rob
Pike Ken Thompson and all um aside from
being known for working at Bell labs and
um you know having a strong um having a
strong hand in developing C and and Unix
they actually developed um some other
languages um uh namely one which could
basically be seen as the precursors to
go so even though go is a pretty new
language in its current form it contains
um a lot of the effort and a lot of the
um the lessons learned from from earlier
efforts uh earlier efforts at go um that
said the first stable release um was in
May 2012 so it's actually just over a
year old um the current version is
1.1 uh so everything that we're going to
talk about tonight um is going to be
prefaced by the fact that it's a
language that's about a year old
um for contrast python was a year old in
I believe
1993 um so we're going to be comparing
with a lot of languages that are in many
ways much more developed um at the same
time go will hold up uh go does actually
hold up pretty
well go is developed um by Google it um
it is not quote Google's programming
language um a number of the people who
do work on it or none of the people who
are on the team do work at Google um at
the same time it's completely open
source effort in fact there are um there
are two compilers available GC and GCC
go um they they intentionally don't want
to create a single canonical
implementation it's very much um an it's
very much um an open language and open
project in every sense uh of the word um
but Google decided to um create and
sponsor this uh to address needs that
they have for themselves for managing
Distributing for well for systems
programming in general um systems
programming is typically done in C or
you know similar language maybe C++
something but quite frankly those
languages haven't aged very well they
still do a very good job of what they
were intended to do back in you know let
say 1979 don't get me wrong but it's not
like C in 2012 offers um if you were to
design a language in 2012 to take
advantage of some of the things that we
can do now that we couldn't back then
you would design something very
differently from say C++ at least uh at
least I would um and uh because of that
they uh you know they uh they decide to
sponsor a new programming language that
will address some of these concerns that
they have uh and it's actually worked
out very well um aside from um a number
of other companies that have also picked
up using go um Google now uh uses it um
to to to power the entirety of dl.
gooogle uh.com so Google is in fact not
just using in production but using it in
production for um for out facing system
as well um originally was written in C++
the primary primary use Cas is to was
intended to take maner away from C but
um it replaces C++ pretty well so some
of the design goals that uh went into
creating go um as I said managing
current and distributed systems easy
this is something that you cannot do
very well and see yes you can write
concurrent C code know it is really not
very much fun um try dealing with
threads in C and um or any language
where you don't actually get um where
you don't have garbage collection um and
it it quickly becomes um uh quickly
becomes a Big M uh another goal even
though this is um pight orthogonal is to
simplify collaboration between multiple
developers uh anytime you have a large
software engineering project uh you have
the problem of everybody using their own
subset of language having their own
Styles having their own um idioms and uh
you also suffer from the fact that as
you go on the project let's say it's a
6month or 12-month project you know more
about the project in month four month 8
than you did in month one and you need
to refactor along the way that can often
times be a pretty messy process when you
have multiple people on board go is
designed as a language to be very simple
so that everyone uses exactly the same
subset of the language if you can do it
if you found the way to do it you've
probably found the right way to do it
because there's pretty much only one way
to do it um as a result it actually
becomes very easy to refactor there's a
lot of built-in tooling that lets you do
that uh fairly easy which we'll talk
about of it um same thing with evolving
code bases and finally it needs to be
fast uh to both build and deploy
um one of the biggest problems with um
C++ especially and then other languages
too like Scala to a lesser extent is
that they're very slow to compile um and
deploying them can actually be um a huge
nightmare go not only has an incredibly
fast compiler um but it also supports uh
it also supports cross compilation very
easily so I can actually compile
something on this computer and run it on
my Android phone without any issue
that's not something that you can do
very easily in a lot of languages if at
all so taking a step back at a bit um I
uh I gave a presentation actually um
about a month ago on using python for
data science uh and it was very
interesting because as I was giving this
presentation I realized how different um
it was in 2012 versus if I've been doing
it in 2009 because um quite frankly a
lot of the tooling that exists now in
Python uh didn't exist at the time or at
least was nowhere near as convenient and
I remember this because um when I was at
OK Cupid that should actually be 2010
not 29 um % of the work that we were
doing uh was a munging and all that we
did in Python and then about 20% was the
actual statistical analysis and that's
what we did in R um from what I gather
this seems to be a pretty typical
workflow at most places um only about
20% of your time even if you're doing
statistical work is spent doing
statistical analysis you need to do a
lot of pre-processing a lot of munging
um a lot of of data cleanup may not be
the fun stuff but it's certainly the
stuff that can be really important
because if you lose anything in the
process um you know there goes there
goes your entire the basis of your
entire
analysis so looking at where python was
in 2009 it was usable for data science
but it wasn't anywhere near what it is
today um how many people have used or
heard of pandas um okay so most people
for those of you haven't um pandas is
basically uh it tries to Port a lot of
our paradigms to python um I shouldn't
say tries it does and it does so very
well so you can do things like data
frames um and manipulations and um uh
yeah manipulations of data in a way that
would be very Ematic in R but doing this
natively in Python and it's really nice
because R actually has a very nice
Paradigm for for dealing with data and
dealing with data Transformations um but
panas didn't actually exist yet I think
it came out um like early in 2011
something like that and um certainly uh
wasn't widely used for a while rpy
thankfully has ex did exist um rpai for
those of you who don't know is a way
that you can call R code natively from
within python um numpy existed but a lot
of the other aspects of the scipi tool
chain um didn't exist um or at least
were were very underdeveloped at the
time compared to what they were today so
while python had all the munging Tools
in place there's a reason that we only
used it for about um 80% of the work and
not for the final 20% and that's because
most of the numerical tools were a
little bit lagging the number one thing
actually that was L that was lagging and
still to some extent is in Python is the
actual statistical libraries that are
available um a large reason for that is
just academics as um as many of you
might know Academia at large is very low
to switch languages and very um very
reluctant to switch tooling so they're
about the last to catch on to anything
so anything that's Cutting Edge and
coming Cutting Edge in the realm of
Academia is probably going to be written
in whatever is the oldest possible tool
that people are still using um so for
that reason um a lot of it wasn't coming
out in Python at the
time go in 2013 actually resembles in
many ways um python in 2009 um a lot of
munging tools are available and some
numerical tools maybe not as many as
were in Python in 2009 um but it's but
the analogy um still holds there are
numerical tools which are still very
much Works in progress at this point um
go python will provide um cpython
bindings which is really helpful in case
you actually want to interface with um
python code from go um and go Matrix
which is written by John asith um
provides some Vector uh Matrix
operations I've used it before it's
probably you know rough pass it might be
like using numeric would have been
before before num numai came along but
but it does do the job unfortunately
there's not really a clear equivalent to
something like pandas yet I'd say that
that's kind of like the icing on the
cake in terms of data science tools um
and that's just that isn't there yet in
Python sorry in
go that said go still provides a lot of
advantages for um for statisticians um
even in its current form the first thing
is that it's very fast both in runtime
and compilation I separate these because
I want to point out that yes it is a
compiled language but something that a
lot of statisticians or a lot of data
scientists don't really use on a day on
a daily basis for their work we tend to
prefer interpreted languages I think
every single one of the languages that
uh we mentioned beforehand um was uh was
an interpreted language but the
compilation of go is um is pretty fast
um that was an explicit design goal uh
of the language um they do a lot of
tricks behind the surface or sorry
behind the scenes to make sure that the
language um stays that way go also
provides native concurrency don't think
any of the other languages that we
talked about before did R certainly
doesn't r a single threaded python um
has the global interpreted lock which is
you know um the ban of every python
programmers existence at this point um
but go was designed from the beginning
to allow native not just native access
to concurrency but easy access to
concurrency and there's a big difference
we'll get to that um a little bit later
on um I separate concurrency from
parallelism um because a lot of go
programmers like to when they're talking
about it concurrency for those who don't
understand understand the distinction or
aren't familiar with it concurrency is
the separation of of your program into
separate into separate components that
may or may not be run at the same time
the idea behind concurrency is making
your code more modular and more um and
more isolated isolating into individual
components parallelization is the act of
actually executing things simultaneously
you can have concurrency without
parallelism just run any concurrent
program on you know on a single thread
or on um on a single coree and you'll
you'll have concurrency without parallel
so a couple of other advantages are that
you can call other language from within
go very easily and then finally the type
system you have the safety of static
typing but you have the flexibility um
of dynamic typing via interfaces um this
is something which I was a little bit
reluctant to um to use coming from other
Dynamic languages like Python and from R
having used it a bit it's incredibly
difficult to go back because you
actually uh with goost type system you
lose very little in the way of
flexibility you gain so much in the way
of code life
liability these are the two
disadvantages of go I talked about
number two a little bit already the
first one is just that it's a pretty new
language it's less than 2 years old um
that said the um it's coming along very
fast um I'm incredibly impressed with
the amount of tooling that's already
available for go but I mentioned this so
that you know remember like we have to
compare this to where you know python
might have been in like 1994 in order to
get um more apples to apples um
comparison with the amount of tooling
available so let's get to the speed um
goes about 10 times faster than Python
and that means about 50 times faster
than R depends on what kind of Benchmark
that you're using but certainly when
you're doing anything that's computation
heavy go is going to be a huge win for
you and that's just um and that's just
dealing with you know that's not even
taking the concurrency aspect um into
into into uh as far as the compilation
speed goes um I actually tested this on
my computer your results May Vary but go
compiled faster than it takes the python
uh interpreter start up so even though
you're dealing with a compile language
you're probably not going to notice that
go go compiles incredibly incredibly
quickly um and uh and in fact there's
even a tool called G run which you can
use to um invoke go invoke the go
compiler um from the Shang like the you
know hashtag or like pound app um so you
can use it as if it were a general
purpose scripting language um a little
bit about the type system it's
statically typed but the type inference
makes static typing incredibly painless
um so this is a little um example what
you might see AAL 5 um that's just um
variable assignment and then um so see
yeah B col equals um add one a add one
is a function that just returns an
integer in this case b b receives its
type it's a sign um coming from a
dynamic language uh background Dynamic
langes this might not be too surprising
but you tell us to Joba programmers and
they kind of you know get their hands up
in the air because they don't understand
the status you don't have to write inut
do you mean um so uh static typing is
pretty painless you'll notice here there
are only two places that I actually even
need to write um even need to write the
type and that's in um and that's in the
function signature um you'll find that
you very rarely need to write types out
and go um but you still get the benefit
of of them being there of all the static
time um all the compile time uh checks
for um interfaces which we'll get to um
a little bit later provide some of the
benefits of D typing um and combined
this makes refactoring and debugging a
lot easier because the go compiler is
incredibly incredibly strict what do I
mean by strict um not only will it not
do any implicit cast it won't even let
you um have unused L values in your
program in in fact in this case this
program will not compile because B is
not actually used anywhere I'm assigning
to a variable and I'm not actually using
it this is going to be really weird to
you when you first start using go you're
going to you're going to start looking
for ways to turn this off you're going
to start looking for compiler Flags no
get used to this it's a very very good
thing chances are if you're assigning um
if you're assigning to L values and
you're not actually reading them
anywhere that's because your code has a
bug that's not because the compiler has
a bug it is very weird I agree but
you'll grow but you will grow a love it
so getting started with go um two things
one let's say if you're coming from a
python um background um you're probably
familiar with the with the Zen of python
begins explicit is better than implicit
um if you've never seen it just open up
Python and type import this um it's
really good sometimes you're just like
looking at really um you know horrible
PHP code and um just like open open that
up and it'll it'll comment it's like
nice little meditation there um so go
fits the Zen of python very well in fact
I would argue that go fits the Zen of
python better than python itself does um
that's a an argument that's probably a
little bit beyond the scope of this talk
but um you'll you'll grow to love um
both go format which is a tool that
basically enforces Go's equivalent of p8
for python in go um it means that
everyone's go code is standardized and
is formatted the exact same way so you
can very easily read anybody's go code
you don't have any of the same issues
that you know let's say if you're coming
from a certain other language which is
run in the browser and interacts with
the Dom and where people don't
understand whether or not semicolons are
optional none of that you everything
everything is done uh via go format um
the main thing that you will miss is
duct typing um that will probably happen
for a couple of weeks um but then you'll
learn to use interfaces and you won't
think about that typing again um um by
the way I forgot to mention I've been
I'm basing my timeline on on go not just
on other people but also on myself I've
been using go um at work pretty much
every day for about the past year um so
this is all based on uh you know my own
personal firsthand experiences with the
language and using it specifically for
statistical work um another thing you
might be interesting is go python it's a
presentation I gave at the New York
python uh meet up a few months back um
if you've got a python background that
might be um a good place to start in
terms of getting started the language
for programmers um who here actually
uses S3 and S4 methods like regularly
okay and that's like two people out of
the entire room that raise their hands
for um for for using R that's a problem
um that to me shows uh you know some of
the deficiencies of RS object model um I
will say that g struts and methods are
way easier to use they're incredibly
simple and sometimes embarrassingly so
but um they still get the job done very
well you will have no fear uh you'll
have no fear no um no trouble them you
like like python you'll like the speed
reliability but the things you're going
to miss are some of the more functional
um aspects that that are provides like L
apply R apply um all those things go is
not meant to be a very functional
programming language it does support
first class functions that's about it it
doesn't have map reduce um apply all
those nice things yes they're a little
bit it's a little bit weird and awkward
not to use them at first but again um
you will get used to it um the number
one thing that you'll miss which I won't
apologize for because because uh sorry
which I will apologize for because um
you know as soon as no getting around
you don't have the same um diverse
section of advanced uh statistical
packages yet um it just doesn't exist
probably in another 2 years um or so uh
I'll be saying something very different
let's hope but for the time being um go
remains something that more is more
likely to replace python in um in your
daily workflow with a munging than it is
to replace r with a
St um couple of tips um STS are
lightweight and basically cover this
main thing is let the compiler guide you
the compiler is strict enough that if
you're doing something right or wrong
the compiler um is smart enough to let
you know when I was getting started with
the language I wouldn't actually go
around Googling things i' basically wait
until the compiler sto giving me errors
I still do that when refactoring um
probably not the best uh way to do it
but it's actually very easy you can
still you follow like a trail
breads so here's just like sort of some
basic um some basic uh some basic go um
here's a function declaration as I
mentioned before it actually won't
compile um but I do this to um
illustrate uh the two ways you can do
variable assignment so this is one way
that's the short hand where the type is
inferred and this way is the long hand
notice that there's no call equals there
it's just an equal sign um you'll find
yourself doing the the second form of
assignment more often than the first but
um I need to mention this because we'll
be looking at um some more complicated
code examples uh
shortly um one concept that's probably
new to most people from almost any
language the concept of a zero value um
a zero value is slightly different from
the from the concept from the way that
um that languages like Java handle this
by default an uninitialized value has
the zero value for the type and it's a
little bit weird to get used to but it
will um it will force you to design your
application in such a way that the
default value actually has some sort of
meaning um this is probably one of the
most subtle points about go that I
underestimated at first um but it really
changes the way that you design and up
your architecture code the zero types
are probably um what you would pretty
much imagine there's zero for all the
numerical types the empty string for the
string um nil for pointers and for um
and for maps and for uh and for channels
channels are something we'll get to um
in a moment um for loops and if
statements uh again nothing too
surprising here this is the way that you
do a a US slicing go um for blank comma
Name colon equals range um this is um
this is a way of discarding a value
instead I could have put I there um and
that would have given me the index think
of like enumerate in Python if you use
that um but I decided to discard it
mostly to show you what it looks like
when you discard a value but also so
that um because I'm not using the um and
if name is not equal to the um nothing
too surprising there error handl this is
the other thing you're likely not um not
to familiar with unless you've got a lot
of background uh with c um I like err
goes error handling because it falls as
z a python explicit is better than
implicit instead of raising exceptions
you turn errors and go and this is yes
this is an idium from yes it is a little
bit weird if you're used to um jav like
Java tring setings everywhere um but it
actually causes errors to be much more
visible in the code um so when you call
when you create when you call any
function if it does something which
could possibly have an error you return
the error value and you check that when
you call that this way you know whether
your error this way you don't actually
have a problem of you can call a
function and you don't know whether or
not um an exception is going from you
don't know whether or not you have to
surround something with a tri catch
block you know very clearly because you
can see the error right there um right
the
code here's how you do a struct um the
main oops the main thing that uh you
want to note here is that there's no
inheritance that's a design goal um
again uh grow very much to like it
instead of inheritance um you have
interfaces which are a much better way
um I think to re. code one uh subtlety
I'd like to point out here is that this
is capitalized that is not what this
means is that that this is going to be a
PR this is going to be private uh to the
package and that is going to be public
you can think of it basically as public
and package um the way they are in Java
um another little Quirk about the
language that takes them getting used to
but um but it makes it much it makes it
easy because you don't actually have to
look anywhere to know whether or not a
field is exported you just know whether
or not um it's
capitalized so interfaces um in Java you
uh I keep making these comparisons Java
uh most people use Java at some point or
have some familiarity yes no okay enough
enough my mods um unlike in Java you
don't have to declare um interfaces um
explicitly in Java you have to say such
and such implements you know comparable
or whatever um in go instead if you
provide the methods of the interface you
satisfy the interface this is really
nice because you can that means that you
can actually satisfy the interfaces for
a package that you don't even know
exists yet the package doesn't have
necessarily be compiled with with
support for that or even written with
support for that in mind you can you
will already satisfy it um this is not
duct typing um I've gotten in trouble
before for sometimes explaining this
like duct typing even though I think
it's a good analogy um but the
similarity is that you can just simply
you can use the struct and it will quote
just work um but unlike Dynamic
languages this is checked at compile
time because all the methods of the
object are known at compile time this is
really nice because this as I said gets
you the flexibility of dynamic typing
but you still get the safety of knowing
whether or not your method call will
actually work there's no no method error
or um I don't know what what's it called
it R um the equivalent you don't you
don't get it you don't get any of these
problems because you actually know at
compile time that that method exists and
Returns the type of value um that you
needed to so here's an example of um of
an interface um it's also an example of
um of a method col i' like just accept
it a little bit for a moment um type
account interface sorry let's talk let's
look at this for a moment um
typechecking construct balance in super
secret ID in 64 what I'm saying here is
that anything is an account as long as
it has a method that takes an INT and
returns an error right here what I'm
doing is defining a method on a checking
account type uh you probably want a
pointer to checking account for theer
this is not this is not actually going
to um this is not going to do what you
think it is um I mentioned I I
intentionally wrote this so that I could
demonstrate um um the fact that go will
automatically reference the poters not
because I actually want to deposit money
to thank you for pointing that out
though I'll spend this a moment for
everone no miss that um so right here
this is just the um implicit parameter
self in um in Python um although unlike
python you actually don't use self you
usually write something that's a little
bit more descriptive but right here um
I'm defining the deposit method and
doing something and then returning an
error in this case there is no error
because there's actually nothing that
could happen here um so returning nil
returning nil is the way of saying there
is no error you know continue nicely so
often times in Reading go code you'll
find the line if error is not equal to
nil you know do something which is
basically your way of doing error
checking um as sorry what's your name j
as Jay very kindly pointed out um this
will not actually um do anything because
um this is going to be passed by value
not by reference um so uh the rate that
you would get around this is defining a
method on the pointer um basically on on
a pointer not on the value the reason I
did this is because um often times
methods will be defined on a value so
that when you pass a pointer it will go
will automatically deference that um I
guess I should have mentioned this a
little bit before but go like C does
support pointer types and makes um
referencing and D referencing more or
less explicit unlike C you're probably
not likely to run into any you know
terrible errors with um with pointers
because um of the way that the language
is designed um you
uh you don't have to bother with pointer
arithmetic and all the you know really
nasty things that you're going to trip
up on going to trip up on and see um so
now let's get to the fun stuff here's
what you're probably here for which is
um the concurrency uh ghost concurrency
motto is don't communicate by sharing
memory instead share memory by
communicating um there are limitations
to this but it it basically exists in
contrast to callbacks mutex U you know
mutexes um promises and Futures and
basically all other really nasty stuff
that people have invented to try and
deal with the issue of concurrency um um
the goal is to make read concurrent and
in a synchronous code as easy and also
as easy to read as um writing
synchronous code the way that we do this
is you via go routines um go routines
are something that are unique to go
they're not threads they're not Co
routines and they're not processes um so
now that we def find exactly what
they're not let's talk about what they
are a goutine is simply a function that
is executed concurrently with other go
routines in the same address space um
what this means is uh you you have a
function
um you have a function that is okay back
gines uh gtin are
executing in the in the same address
space um the ideas that they're light
and they're multilex onto multiple OS
threads so unlike other languages where
you might be explicitly defining um you
know here I'm going to request a new
thread here I'm going to Define what's
going to execute in that thread you're
not you're just you're just defining a
function and you're saying this function
is actually independent of all the other
stuff that I'm writing in my code you're
going to let the go runtime decide when
and how to execute um that go routine
and you're going to wash your hands off
of that that's good because you are far
less likely to run into um all the nice
uh concurrency issues that we know from
the five philosophers problems um when
you're not handling this and when you're
letting the go run time uh go run time
do its job it's not going to solve all
of those for you but it's going to solve
it's going to solve a lot of them the
other thing is that it's also much more
likely to be optimal go will know go
will notice when a go routine is
blocking and will then switch another go
routine um you know onto that thread to
uh to operate what's interesting to note
is that this happens and this is in
completely independent of the number of
cores that your machine has you can do
this you can do this using you know only
one single core and in that case only
one go team will execute at a time but
you still have a concurrent program
that's still nice because that still
means that you've written a program
that's modular and when you separated
the components and and you're
eliminating a whole new class of bugs
there um but it also means that when you
then you know execute that um execute
that program on a different computer you
might save um a speed up um a good
analogy here if you're used to the Unix
shell is to think of the um the and
operator to send the process to the
background um once you send it to the
background you don't have to think about
it um and um it'll just do it'll just do
its own work it also won't really return
anything um which is the other key thing
to to think about that's that will
provide the motivation for channels
which we get to in a moment um when I
say that b routines are light I really
mean it um go routines basically cost um
the the the the stack space and almost
nothing more uh so you can and I
actually have done this just to test it
out have um literally hundreds of
thousands of G routines um uh in your
program at one time you're not going to
be running hundreds of thousands of G
routines unless you're dealing with a
computer much larger than um much better
than this one but um um but you still
have them and that means that you can uh
when you're doing work when it which
involves say web scraping or things like
this you're not going to be executing
all them simultaneously but you can at
least separate those components
conceptually and not uh and not be
worrying about them in the the main body
of your program uh so here's a little
synchronicity um by by example um this
is pretty straightforward I don't think
anyone here will have any trouble um
understanding this um but we can run it
and just see um it will greet Alice then
it'll sleep for 3 seconds and then it
will greet Bob um sleep for then sleep
again for 3 seconds and then um and then
die um now let's get to
[Music]
oops here we go now let's do this in a
separate go routine notice how the only
difference that I've actually done here
is I've added the word go in front of um
in front of the function
call
can everyone see that I'm not sure
unfortunately the color scheme didn't
seem to come out too well can people see
in the back see what's happening okay
more or less um so let me run that
[Music]
again uh just in case you missed it so
what's happening is it's instantly
greeting both Alice and Bob and then
it's going to be sleeping the only other
thing I added is the timed out sleep at
the end for 5 seconds um if I hadn't
done that actually you guys can see what
will happen um anyone want to take a
guess
anyone guess what happens when I when I
remove
this
some yeah um the program will exit right
away um that's because your program will
not wait for um for other go routines to
finish their task um this when you first
uh when you first uh think about it
might seem like a bug but actually it's
a good thing it means that you can
actually spawn other go routines and
have them be running in the background
and then as soon as what you're actually
what you care about is done you the
program will exit and you don't have to
worry about other stuff that's already
been happening it'll just it'll just die
immediately um so notice I only added
the um the word go in front of the
function call and that's all that
happened these things uh go basically
handle the rest of this um rest this
forward uh and yes it really is that
easy um a little bit of a comparison to
something that um might be familiar with
other languages callbacks particularly
in JavaScript um the main difference
between the main advantage of using go
routines over callbacks is that go
routines resemble synchronous code
whereas call routin callbacks are more
like synchronous code turned inside out
when you write callbacks you're
basically inverting your entire uh your
entire code process and um you know
callbacks are are go-tos in um in the
Lambda calculus you're inverting exactly
what's happening you're handing off
execution to another point in the
program the whole point of a go routine
by contrast is that this actually looks
like synchronous code if I hadn't
pointed this out to you you might not
even have noticed um that the that the
the call to go actually existed um the
the main uh the main distinct is that
it's very easy to turn a function call
into a go routine um you just add go in
front of it and have to be careful of
any you know closure or variable capture
which um which is understandable but
it's actually very difficult to refactor
synchronous code um into asynchronous
code using callbacks um if anybody uh uh
if you don't believe me just trust me on
this um and if you really don't believe
me just try writing some JavaScript and
um then try taking um you know reach the
first time when you really wish that
You' actually written something um as a
call back instead of um
uh instead of instead of synchrony what
you'll basically have to do is you'll
have to completely invert the remainder
of your function call so that it that it
can be passed into a function um into
into that call back and that's very
nasty to do because you're you've
completely handed off the uh the point
of execution code um something else and
you don't actually know going to be
called again um communication becomes
very difficult when you're dealing with
uh dealing with callbacks luckily go on
the other hand has channels channels
exist to provide a convenient way to
communicate between uh two different go
routines and there's simply a way that
um you can pass data from one go routine
to another in that sense they serve as a
synchronization point when you try to
send on a channel the go routine that is
sending will block when you try to
receive on a channel the goou team that
is receiving will block until it can
receive something on that channel unless
you're sending or receiving on a on on a
channel those go routines are um are
performing all their work
asynchronously so let's uh take a look
at an example
um this
uh see let's um yeah let's take a look
at um what happens all that happens is
it it creets Alice no need to to sit
there let's take a little bit of a
closer look though um what's actually
happening here well first we're making a
Channel um then we are making a call to
to greet Alex and um we're passing in
that channel we're passing in that
channel and then we're pass and then
we're sending the greeting to that
response on the other side we are
waiting for that uh we are waiting for
that greeting and we're receiving from
that channel and then we're printing it
out um and the sleep is just uh I guess
I give that SLE in there um do people do
people uh follow this
so um let's just run it again um you
can
oops trying to do this
uh the other ways a little bit difficult
um so if you look at the order of the
logging statements you can actually see
what's happening there we're continuing
the execution there but we're sleeping
um in the meantime before that that's
actually ready to S so this is going to
this is going to this uh this line is
going to be printed immediately after
the call to to greet is being run it's
not actually going to start blocking
under until we try receiving from that
channel and that channel is not ready to
is not ready to send the signal yet at
that point this go routine is you know
is going to wait for that channel um to
send before it
finishes so um in short go gos make uh
concurrency Easy by making it easy to
reason about and channels make it easy
to share information between go routines
um go thankfully also includes a
built-in race detector this is brand new
since about May and go 1.1 it won't
catch um it won't catch all uh you know
race conditions but it will catch um a
large class of bugs for you um and it's
really uh it's actually really fun um uh
and easy to work with so now let's get
to why we actually want to use this
which is for data processing in go I
basically admitted up front that go is
not really going to be your best tool
yet for the for the numerical actual
number crunching but it is actually a
really good tool already to use for um
for data munching thanks to its native
concurrency features and its higher it's
n native concurrency features its
execution speed and its high
reliability um these are all some tools
that you will get for free when you uh
just in the standard Library um you can
there's an image processing library that
um does both encoding and decoding of um
gifs jpegs and pgs it also does image
composition for you so you can actually
you know draw images and then replace
other images onto onto other images
um there's an XML parser for web
scraping you can part both parse and
send emails with um netmail and uh s
SMTP and you can also do arithmetic on
both um large numbers multi-precision
numbers and uh and complex or imaginary
numbers these are not things that you
get from third party libraries these are
all things that are guaranteed to be
there by the standard Library these are
not things that um most languages
provide for free and certainly not
within the first year uh year or two of
their existence
um and then this isn't even getting into
um the large source of third party
libraries out there so let's look at a
couple of examples some data scraping
and go um this is a client that I wrote
at one point when I was um for work when
I was uh scraping um the angelist API
don't tell Angel SK if any of you guys
know them um but uh the the main thing
to notice here is that I'm basically
creating a function that will allow me
to um decouple the asynchronous breing
from the synchronous rate limiting I
don't I may not know ahead of time what
I'll post these slides by the way later
on you don't have to take a
picture I mean you can if you want but
um might as well save you the trouble
um uh if you're if you're really
interested looking now this is the go
Angel project on GitHub um so I can
write the rest I can write the rest of
my code that actually does all the
client logic assuming that I'm dealing
with a completely synchronous library
and instead all I've done behind the
scenes is passed off the work to a
function that will create a cue for me
and you know perform whatever rate
limiting um that I want on on the
program in concept that or in theory
that's not such a difficult you know or
a hard to understand Concept in many
languages but actually implementing it
can be difficult and certainly you often
times can't Implement that in such a way
that the calling function has absolutely
no idea whether or not um the underlying
work is being performed synchronously or
asynchronously and go you can because
all you're doing is sending or receiving
on channels it's a native concurrency
primitive and um it'll only block when
you when you actually need to block
um so uh some of the applications that
you can think of for um for data science
is that um obviously anytime that you
can split your algorithm into um
multiple or independent components you
you have some potential of
parallelization there um and channels
are really easy to use for signaling
when a job is complete um one thing that
you might want to test out is let's say
you have two um two different algorithms
that um that might uh one might perform
better than the other at runtime but you
have no idea of knowing um beforehand
which one you can use channels to select
the fastest Al um so here's an example
there's actually a select keyword which
will um select the first channel that um
is ready to send a value so let's say
that algorithm one is actually a channel
that's returning you know returning the
value
um you can select an algorithm one and
then you know return return that or
select an algorithm to and return that
this is what I um when I said earlier
that g teams will run in the background
and the program will exit and you don't
need to worry about what else is running
this is where that can come in handy I'm
just going to set off all my work to be
running in two separate go routines I'm
going to pick the first answer that I
get um regardless of which algorithm
that it comes from and I'm going to
return that then the program is going to
die and I don't need to worry about the
fact that the other algorithm is still
running it's going to you know it's
going to be garbage collected um another
use this idian is for um finishing
timeout so I can basically say perform
this algorithm but in case um
in case it doesn't return within 30
seconds you know timeout and return some
sort of an error um these are both
things that I've done um not just with
uh the web paper that um that I was
writing but also for um for some
statistical work here's another example
of data collection of background
computation is a project that I worked
on um this past fall which was um a tool
for um doing live calling the
presidential debates so um did people uh
watch the presidential debates on either
CNN or uh it cspan who who here watch
the presential debates on C on CNN
specifically okay do you guys see the
thing across the bottom of the screen
where you see like this is how much
people you know like what's being said
right now or it's like so this is um
this is a little website that will do
the same thing but um will allow anybody
with a phone um in order to uh allow
anybody with a phone to um to
participate as opposed to CNN which
randomly selects um 30 30 people that
are somehow supposed to be represented
in the entire country um so instead this
will let anybody um you know Slide the
dial um to the left or to the right
favorable or unfavorable and that's the
green line that you can see right there
the blue line on the other hand is
everything that say either everyone is
doing or all of your friends are doing
Etc and this is an easy example of being
able to um Outsource the Outsource the
computation to the background and then
sending it back in a websocket as soon
as it finishes you don't actually you
can separate the components because you
don't actually the green line doesn't
really care about the blue line and vice
versa and in fact the blue line um if
imagine if you had mult multiple
different lines the lines are being
calculated um in different ways I don't
actually care which algorithm Returns
the answer Returns the answer I just
care which one uh returns it faster um
getting back the idea of selecting from
a
channel um one other thing that you guys
might be interested in is writing um C
extensions something that I find our
programmers are less excited about than
python programmers not that anyone's
that excited to write C but um but it's
very easy to do um coo allows you to do
this and as long as you're using um GC
as to GCC go it's very easy to write um
C extensions in go um and in fact also
to make go functions available in C that
said you're almost never going to want
to do this um I should say almost never
but it's it's useful a lot less often
than you might think um most of the
tools that you need um are actually just
much better off written in go um go
takes all the good stuff about C but
basically leaves most of the bad stuff
behind the only reason that you would
really care about this um are if you're
deal dealing with existing C code for
some reason um or you really really
really low memory management and I mean
really low Med memory
management um a couple of other tools
that um I'll leave you guys with um go
Json is something that I wrote for um
automatically generating static stru
definitions when you're doing Json un
marshalling um this is something which
is useful in any static uh in any
statically typed language um but I found
myself when writing these client
libraries um manually uh creating stru
definitions for the the types that I
want to Marshall go Json will um will
save you that trouble and take sample
Json and output um and do some code
generation for you um two things that
were useful in in this program that I
showed um a little bit before MGO
pronounced mango don't ask me I didn't
write it um and reigo which are just MD
and re Cent libraries and go um I
compare this to redus only because it's
something that people oftentimes use for
um Poor Man's concurrency
um in other programming languages
because reddis is um even though it's
single threaded it's easy to use to for
communication between multiple parts of
applications in languages that don't
support native concurrency but uh you're
actually probably better off using
channels in go for communicating between
different parts of your application the
only reason you want to use rdus is if
you need um if you need the persistence
for some
reason um so in short go is um already a
very excellent tool for um for data
scraping data processing and data moning
basically all the same stuff that I
found myself doing at okid in Python for
80% of my work um back in 2009 um go is
not yet but it's becoming a pretty
excellent candidate for work in
scientific computation and uh and
numerical work um it'll probably take
another year or two to get there um
particularly because of the the rate uh
at which Academia picks things up um but
uh but it probably uh can can substitute
as it is right now for maybe about 80%
of your workflow um without much of a
problem so um you know check it out uh
there's a good chance that um that you
guys uh that you guys might like it um
thank
you